never plays the gallery i think  but you never learn that until much  later on i think  but never work for other people at what  you do  always  always remember that the reason that you  initially started working was that there  was something inside yourself that  you've  felt that if you could manifest it in  some way you would understand  more about yourself and how you coexist  with the rest of society  and i i think it's terribly dangerous  for an artist to  fulfill other people's expectations i  think they produce they generally  produce their worst work when they do  that  and if the other thing i would say is  that if you feel safe in the area that  you're working in  you're not working in the right area  always go a little further into the  water than you feel you're capable of  being in  go a little bit out of your depth and  when you don't feel that your feet are  quite touching the bottom  you're just about in the right place to  do something exciting